- [Mark] All right, Johnny what
are we talkin' about today?
- Here we go.
We gonna talk about a little bit.
I talk a lot,
in my interviews I talk a lot about
being down here in Los Angeles.
You know, me running around in the hood.
Runnin' around down here in downtown LA.
You know, different parts of LA.
But I've never shared, you know,
when I went outta state.
You know what I mean?
When I was about 15 years old
this musta been, oo man,
I'd say '87, '88 maybe.
I was about 15 years old and
it was gettin' hot down here.
You know.
MC Texas kept comin' to the house.
You know what I mean?
They kept raidin' the house for my uncle.
And kept raidin' the house
for my brother, you know.
So, it was becoming too
hot at the house, you know.
Every time they raided it,
they'd just take me to jail
and let me out in a few hours
but I didn't like the feeling.
So, I got my Grandmother,
and I told her, you know,
I wanna go to Mexico.
And she said, I already
sent you over there.
You know what I mean?
I already went over there.
I wanted to go back.
Well, she didn't wanna send me.
So, she said, well,
why don't we send you to
Arizona for a little while,
you know, with some people up there?
And I was like, all right,
at least check it out.
You know what I mean?
Lets go.
You know, it was,
the summer was gone, so I was
figurin' it's not that hot.
Still, I got there and it
was fuckin' boiling hot
and we're in the middle of October.
Like, right now, in here it's boiling hot.
You know, I got there and
you know, the school year was passing
and I wanted to get enrolled in school
'cause I just didn't
wanna run around there,
have the cops or the
truant officer catch me
because, remember I went there by myself.
Low and behold, what I did was,
I got some money together,
I got my clothes together
and I went to the bus depot.
Not this one.
The old bus depot.
The one that use to be on 7th and Maple.
Around,
yeah, right there on 7th and Maple,
the old bus depot.
So, I went over there
and I remember when I got there, you know,
some fool snatched my luggage real fast.
Man, I thought he was
tryin' to steal my shit,
so I gave chase to him.
And he's like, hey, hey,
I'm just helpin' you out.
You know, I didn't know
that there was dudes
that would help you take your
luggage wherever it gots to go
and you know, break 'em off,
whatever, change your dollars.
I thought he was robbing me.
You know, I'm young.
15.
He's grabbin' my suitcases.
He's a grown man.
I'm like, man, I get at him.
Anyways, I gave him some change.
I get on the bus.
So, on the way to Arizona,
we're like halfway there
and all the sudden,
the bus pulls over to
the side of the road.
And then I see sirens, you know,
flashing in the windows.
And I'm like, oh shit.
They pull over the fuckin' bus.
Oh man, I hope they didn't fuckin' see me
or you know, they're lookin' for me.
So, I'm thinkin' it's all about me.
Nah, they got on the bus
and took this man and this little kid off.
Then took them both, you know.
So, it was cool.
But I was already bustin'
out my pictures that I took,
you know, me in LA and stuff,
just in case, you know,
'cause I don't got no ID.
You know what I mean?
And a lot of times right there
in that part of the trip to Arizona,
they deport people.
That's by Coachella, Indio, all that area.
They deport a lot of people.
You know what I mean?
And they catch you on the bus by yourself,
no ID, nothing, no one with you,
of course, they're gonna take you.
You know what I mean?
Well, they bypass me.
Cool.
I went all they way to Arizona.
When I got there,
I got there, it was about,
oo, it was late at night.
So, I went, you know what I mean?
Went in the backyard, kicked it.
They got a spot out there.
Kicked it in the backyard.
Wait til the next day.
The next day came.
I was like, okay, what
am I gonna do over here?
You know, I could be sellin' drugs.
You know what I mean?
Outta my Grandma's house.
I could just run wild right here.
Or I could enroll in school
and see what that's like.
You know?
I'm only 15,
so I go to one of my aunts and I'm like,
hey, can you enroll me in school?
She didn't wanna do it,
so my cousin, she ended up doin' it.
They enrolled me in school,
put my Grandmother's address.
Now I'm goin' to school, right.
I'm goin' to school there
and it's,
it's similar to back home
but it's just a lot slower.
You know what I mean?
They ain't doing as much shit.
They're doin' it on the low
but they're not doin'
as much shit as we're doin' back in LA.
You know, they're about
three gears back, you know.
But one time I'm kickin' it,
you know what I mean?
And I was watchin' this dude.
You know, he was Mexican and Puerto Rican.
He lived across the street from me
and I always use to see him at night
comin' back at night.
You know, I'm wonderin' what
the fuck is this dude up to.
You know, so,
one time he walks by.
I call him.
And we smoke a cigarette.
We get to know each other.
Low and behold, I know
this dudes a robber.
You know, he robs all kinds of shit.
You know what I mean?
I'm down there with him and I'm sayin',
fuck it, let's go.
Let's go for a whirl.
You know, see what's up.
He goes, well, I'll be back.
Right now I gotta go get something.
So, he leaves.
He comes back.
When he comes back,
he has this,
I gotta be that year,
a Ford truck.
A big one.
King cab.
A long bed.
I'm talkin' about high as
truck and bad mother fucker.
Four wheel drive, everything, right.
It looks brand new.
So, I'm like where'd
you get this truck at?
And he was like, man, I
just went to the car lot,
by the side of the office, man.
Open the shit.
All the keys were hangin'.
I grab the key, got in it and took off.
I'm like, yeah, but
there's poles and chains.
He goes, nah, man.
He goes, I'll show you.
He took me over there and it's straight
because all those used car
lots always have one pole
that comes up and then you
can lay it on the ground.
And that lays the chain out.
You know, I never knew that.
I never knew that til he showed me.
So, we went over there.
When we took the pole out, laid it down,
went inside the office.
He went inside, pulled all the keys out.
We're all looking the keys
and boom I see this nice ass Trans Am.
I'm like, oh, I'll take the Trans Am.
It's blocked in.
So, I'm like, okay, we
gotta move the white truck.
And you know, what it is,
it's just a, you know, a set like this,
a set which is a gang of keys in there
and they all have what year,
what color, what model.
So, you just look at
the car lot, get the key
and boom, presto, you
know, you got the car,
so, we ended up getting
about three or four that night.
Now, we're cruisin' around.
We're wonderin' where we gonna take 'em.
So, I said, you know what?
We could wait til the morning
and then we could drive to Mexico.
I mean, and Mexico's only 13 miles.
So, I figured, the worst
that could happen is
we gotta walk back.
To me, that's the worst that could happen.
So, we go.
There's about five of us.
We go in about three cars.
We go there with a truck and two cars.
We go over there.
We meet some dude, we met
on this side over here.
He's talkin' about his aunts
and everything live right there
and they did.
And they wanna buy all the
cars as soon as we get there.
So, we got there and
we stay a little while.
We went an partied with dude.
We went deeper into Mexico.
We went to the border of,
it's called Al de Lones.
It's in between San Louis,
Mexico and Chicale, like that.
Yeah, Mexicali or one of those.
It's right in the middle.
It's a little ass border.
It's got like, one car goes in,
one car goes out.
Small ass border,
by the canyons.
You gotta drive along the
Colorado to get there.
You know what I mean?
It's a small ass border.
So, we get there and we
rolled through like nothin'.
Boom, we rolled through.
And at first when we
get there, dudes like,
come on let's go to the bar, you know.
And I didn't know that
you could be any age
to drink in Mexico.
You just gotta act right.
You know what I mean?
If you act a fool, they're
gonna take you to jail.
You're fucked.
But if you act right, you know,
you can have women sitting on your lap.
I had a woman sitting on my lap.
I was 15.
You know what I mean?
I was buyin' rounds, buyin' rounds
'cause, you know, over
there, like 20 bucks, man,
will buy you like seven rounds in a bar.
You know, with everybody there.
So, we're buyin' shit.
We're buyin' shit.
My uncle walks in.
Boom.
My grandfather's brother.
I'm thinkin', oh shit, man,
I'm through with wonderin' this.
Who's gonna tell.
Nah.
He said, what's up.
How you doin', man.
Grabbed himself two broads,
sat 'em on his lap.
And then started partyin'.
And then I was like, okay.
So, he ain't gonna tell on me.
So, we went over there and we had,
okay, they dude told us that
we were gonna get 2500 a truck
and 2,000 a car.
Now, you know, when you get somewhere,
always in the deal,
when you get somewhere,
a mother fucker wants to change it up.
We're in Mexico.
What could we say?
You know what I mean?
He's tryin' to short change us like 2,000.
But what could we say, we're in Mexico.
You know what I mean?
Once we're over here, we got no backing.
I'm all the way in LA.
Where we're at in Arizona,
that's 13 miles away,
so I'm like, damn, this
fool's gonna get us.
Fuck it.
We told him, yeah, yeah, whatever.
So, we got it.
We put the money in our pockets.
Now, remember, we're there all day.
What happened was, we lost track of time.
The border closes at
eight o'clock exactly.
It's like 10 til eight.
So, we're like, fuck.
We got no chance of
gettin' a car or nothin'.
We gotta run.
So, we run, man.
We run.
We get there, it's like
five minutes to close.
We get there.
We go through.
Boom, boom, boom, with our money.
Now, we're stuck and
we got 13 miles to walk
along the Colorado.
Now, 13 miles is a long time
when you ain't got no water.
It's a fuckin' far ass hike.
Believe me, I did it.
We did it because we didn't
have no ride, nothin'.
A little ways there and this
old man in his RV and his wife
pull over to the side, gave us some water
and told us we could hand on his RV
and get a ride to the RV place.
And that's the like halfway.
So, we drank water, whatever.
We get on this RV and we're all hangin' on
and he gives us a ride
all the way over there.
So, we're halfway through our trip.
We're like maybe eight miles into it.
I mean, this has taken it's toll, man.
My legs are burning.
You know what I mean?
Constantly thirsty.
And it's fuckin' hot over there.
You know what I mean?
But when you're in Arizona
and you're there for awhile,
you become accustom to the heat.
Like anywhere else.
You know what I mean?
But the heat is so hot what we're in.
I use to see my little cousins
walkin' barefoot on the cement
and it's like 115 degrees.
You know what I mean?
I use to be like, man, their
feet must be fuckin' hard
or something because
it's really hot out here
and they're walkin' like nothin'.
But bein' that they live
there all their life
I guess they become accustom to that heat.
You know, I try to put my
foot down on the cement.
Hell no.
You could fry an egg
on that fuckin' cement.
You know, and they're walkin'
all the way to the market barefooted.
You know what I mean?
And that's pavement, inside,
walk rocks, everything.
It ain't phasing them.
So, you know, when I was in Arizona
we kinda got use to the heat,
so that was a little up from us walking.
But we're about maybe a
quarter of a mile still,
a quarter of the way to go still
and I'm thinkin', man, we
ain't gonna make it, man.
This shit's too fuckin' hot, man.
Here comes one of the fellas, man.
He came from the school.
He went to the border,
seen it was closed,
came back around,
seen us walking.
Went all the way down,
turned around,
came in and picked us up.
You know what I'm sayin'?
He picked us up.
Dude was only 13 years old.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I gave him his props.
He was only 13 ,he came for us.
You know, no one asked him.
No one told him shit.
You know what I mean?
He ear hustled our conversation.
That's how he found out
where we were going.
He wanted to go.
He went and got a car and
everything so he could go
and he was only 13.
But when he came with the car, you know,
we were relieved.
We're like, man, fuck.
We each gave him a couple
hundred dollars each,
you know, 'cause he came to pick us up
in the middle of nowhere, you know.
So, we get back over there
and you know, you got,
over there in Arizona,
you gotta understand that
they're not as quick as us.
They're not so adapt
to cars getting stolen.
You know what I'm saying?
If something happens big,
comes out in the paper,
everybody's talkin' about it.
Now, there's cars coming up missing
from those car lots, like,
four or five every other night.
We're takin' em.
We're just takin' 'em.
There's, oo shit,
over there must be 20, 30 car lots.
You know what I mean?
And they're all the same.
It's all the same build.
They're built all the same way.
You know, I don't understand.
That's not really burglary proof
but bein' that we're over
there and it's a lot slower,
maybe they're not too
hip to lockin' that shit
behind something where you can't get in.
You know what I mean?
And they didn't do it.
So, everywhere we went,
everywhere we went, man, they
like open the front door,
I looked in, boom.
Whole set of keys, man.
Everywhere we went.
We did that.
We did that and
you know the reason I bring it up
is because I was on a whole
different page with those dudes.
There was no gang bangin' involved.
I didn't have no enemies over there.
I mean, there was dudes
from hoods over there,
you know, and they were from LA hoods
but they moved to Arizona.
They started,
came in Arizona.
You know, those dudes didn't say shit.
It was more the dudes that came
from LA and went over there
and transplanted over there in LA,
so like they're runnin'
something, you know.
So, we got in shit with
'em a couple of times.
You know what I mean?
In front of the school, down
in their hood, you know.
But other than that, it was cool.
You know,I didn't have to worry
about walkin' down the street over there
and gettin' shot in the back.
You know what I mean?
I don't gotta look over
my shoulder, you know.
Right there you can drink beer.
You know what I mean?
The cops don't really sweat shit.
Like they sweat shit in LA, you know.
And I was really comfortable
over there, you know,
and I was thinkin', man,
I might just stay here.
You know what I mean?
And get a girlfriend.
And you know, raise a
family and just kick it.
But nah, it ain't happening.
You know, it ain't happening.
About shit, three weeks into my stay,
phone call comes from the hood.
You know what I mean?
Hey, you gotta come back.
My little brother got out
and he's running amuck.
You know what I mean?
I don't want him out there by himself.
So, I'm like, damn, how
am I gonna get back home?
You know what I mean?
How am I gonna get back home?
I'm thinkin' they Greyhound,
that's too fuckin' long, man.
That shit is too long.
And I had some money on me
from the cars, you know.
So, I got one of the neighbors,
the white boy right there
and I was like, hey man,
let's go to LA, you know.
I'll take you over there with me.
We'll kick it.
You know what I mean?
You know a lot of my family.
We'll go over there and post up.
He's like, man, that's a good idea.
Let's do it.
So, fuck it.
We loaded his car.
We got in his car and
we drove all the way.
Halfway there, his shit broke down
in the middle of nowhere.
I'm talkin' about, just fuckin' mountains
and fuckin' bushes.
Nothin'.
You know what I mean?
Nobody stopping.
All the sudden, here
some the highway patrol.
That fool stopped, helped us.
We fixed the car and we got on, you know.
Out of everybody, he stopped,
the highway patrol.
No on else was stopping, man.
Mother fuckers were flyin' by.
Zoom.
You know what I mean?
I try and tell him, wait, you know.
Fuck, help us out.
Nobody.
And it's fuckin' hot.
We're in the middle of the fuckin' desert.
We're like about 10 miles from Glamis.
That's the fuckin' sand dunes,
you know, over there in that area.
You know, it's the sand dunes
and we're fuckin' just,
we're stranded, man.
Well, he helps us out and
we get to a gas station.
We call some heads, they come and get us
but we're, you know, we're halfway there.
And you know, when they came and got us,
you know, we had some stuff
we brought from over there
'cause you know, in Arizona, you know,
you can do certain things
you can't do in California.
You know, you can acquire certain things
you can't acquire in California.
You could acquire 'em in Arizona.
It's a different law, you know.
I seen and old man walk into the store
and he had two Colt 45 pistols on his lap
with a gang of bullets
like that, you know.
And he was maybe like,
he had to be at least 70, 80.
You know what I mean?
He had these two guns right there
and he was walkin' down
the street like nothin'.
And I was like, how the
fuck are you walkin' down,
You know what I mean?
With his guns like that.
I said, I know he ain't no cop.
He's kinda old to be a cop.
So, I asked the man at the store.
I'm like, how does that guy
just come in here with guns?
He's like, well, Arizona law,
you can brandish firearms
on you hips, you know.
You can have a firearm on your hip
as long as its visible, and you know,
you're showing it.
You can have that.
I didn't know that
and then little by little I
started seeing more people
strapped up, strapped up.
I seen this dude had a
fuckin' belt buckle like this
and it had a little ass gun
with like four bullets in it.
And it was his belt buckle.
And it shot 22s.
Little ass,
little ass gun on his belt buckle.
And you just push a button,
that shit fall right in your hand.
I seen that one.
That was right after I seen
that man with the Colt 45s
'cause now I was interested.
Me and Dan, while we were in Arizona,
you could just buy 'em over the counter,
like, fuck, we ain't
getting close over there.
So, I do my thing, you know,
and they handle their business.
Like I was sayin', we got halfway there
and that's what we're
really concerned about.
When the highway patrol came,
we weren't really trippin'
because he was by himself
and if he was gonna look through the car
he had to look really good
where our hiding place was at
you know, 'cause we made a hiding place
where it's even hard for
us to fuckin' find it.
You know what I mean?
So, we made it, you know.
We get back to LA and as
soon as we get back to LA,
my little brother he's in jail.
I'm like, what's he in jail for?
Oh, he got busted for
a shooting last night.
I said, I told him when I
called, I was coming the next day
but he couldn't wait.
You know, he was fresh outta jail.
You know what I mean?
And when you're fresh
outta jail, you know,
you got all that animosity built up,
all those fuckin' rumors you
hear about you girlfriend.
You know what I mean?
About your homeys.
So, you might get out
there and smash everybody.
You know what I mean?
But I can honestly tell you the truth,
there's not enough time
to smash everybody.
You know what I mean?
Everybody ain't worth it.
Not all ass whoopin's are good, you know.
You might whip a fool's ass
and you know, he's gonna call the cops.
You know, that's what I'm really
concerned about these days.
That, you know, oh, when I
was in Arizona, you know,
they call the cops for beatin' up a dude
and they just came, broke us up and left.
Over here, I got busted
for beatin' up a dude.
They arrested me, wanna
give me assault and battery.
And both of us were bleeding.
But bein' that he called,
you know what I mean?
He called 'em on me.
He said I shoulda called
but I'm not a cop caller.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I can't do that.
It's really hard for me to
call any law enforcement
because of the fact
that I just don't agree
with a lot of their tactics.
You know, the things they do.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't agree with them.
You know what I mean?
And right now they're off the chain,
so I don't call 'em for nothin'.
You know what I mean?
And I like to get my camera and watch 'em
'cause they're always
doin' some dumb shit.
You know what I mean?
They're always doin' some dumb ass shit.
But over there in Arizona, you know,
but before I left, I
had got a can of paint
and I started sniffin' paint.
And when I was sniffin' paint,
I thought my cousin was
tryin' to set me up.
So, I ended up beatin' her up.
The cops came, arrest me,
take me to jail, put me in juvenile hall
and the one thing I remember
about that juvenile hall
is when you get there,
they got this thing called adjustment.
For a whole day, you
have to sit in your room,
with your mattress rolled up.
Your water, food, whatever.
But you can't lay down
for a whole day.
And this is in Arizona juvenile hall.
You know, they don't let you sit down
for a whole fuckin' day.
And I didn't understand that.
You know, that's like in humane.
You know.
You can use the bathroom, you know,
but you had to stay sitting there.
You couldn't lay down,
close your eyes, you know,
they'd bang on your door.
Bam, bam, bam.
You know what I mean?
And I was like, how the
fuck does that work,
adjustment for a child.
You know what I mean?
So, you know, Arizona has
its good and its bads.
You know.
Arizona, you do something,
you rob a liquor store,
they give you like, 27 years, man
but you'll only be doin' like six, seven.
But they give you this way
out number, like 56 years.
You see a dude out in like five years.
You know what I mean?
Their laws are different than us.
They run their shit different.
You know, everything.
Their IDs look different.
Everything is,
it's more like a western
shit that I notice.
They got more like a
different heritage back then,
behind them, you know.
I use to go,
oh, we use to ditch school
and I remember when I was in high school,
we use to ditch school,
like 15 of us.
And we would go to the Colorado River.
It was like three blocks
away from the high school.
So, we'll go and we'll take plastic bags
and when the truant officers
and the cops would come,
we'd just jump in the water
and swim to the other side
and get out over there
and fuck you, you know.
They can't come on that side.
It's not their jurisdiction.
That's California, you know.
And so, we'd go back and forth.
You know what I mean?
And fuck with the cops.
And the only ones we
didn't really fuck with
was the fuckin' border patrol
'cause those fools don't give a fuck.
They'll go anywhere,
on any side, you know,
in the water, they'll come and get you.
They have, believe me.
So, we were doin' that for awhile.
We were ditching.
And because we were ditching,
more and more people were finding out,
so i think at the last
ditch it party that we had,
that we musta had like
50, 60 people there.
And the cops came and raided.
Truant officers, everything.
A lot of people got in trouble.
And the whole thing, you know,
what I hated about the situation
is when they all got in trouble,
all their fingers went,
(exhales sharply)
to me.
You know, they all pointed to me.
And you know, and I kinda figured it
because they weren't doin'
nothin' like that over there.
They weren't stealin' no cars.
They weren't fuckin' jumping people.
They weren't doin' that.
They were just goin' to school.
They're fuckin' thing
was to go to the arcade
or you know,
go fuckin' play in an
abandoned building, you know.
They didn't know nothin'
about us go take some cars,
drive 'em over here and you
thousands in your pockets.
So, a lot of those dudes
that I did that with,
you know, a lot of 'em now are in jail.
You know, I talk to a couple of 'em.
You know, maybe they're
still doin' their thing.
But I kinda feel bad 'cause you know,
I kinda started 'em off on that bad trail.
You know what I mean?
But I let 'em know, you
don't gotta come with me.
I'll go myself.
I'll just come pick you
up afterward with girls.
But no, they wanna go.
They wanna take their own car.
They wanna look cool.
Okay, go ahead, you know.
So, a few of them, I know,
went to jail behind that.
Behind fingerprints.
'Cause remember, I just got there,
so, they didn't have me down on file.
Those fools, though, they went to jail.
Cops came to their house,
raided their shit,
took all their dad's guns,
took their guns,
fuckin' took everything.
You know what I mean?
And took them to jail, you know.
And what was crazy was,
they got booked for other shit
that I knew nothing about.
And it was suppose to
be all of us together.
So, these fools were
pulling some slick shit
and they got caught up
because they pulled slick shit, you know.
But you know, I wanted
to show you a day about,
I'm always talkin' about
here in LA, you know.
But it's anywhere you go, you know.
Anywhere you go, if you're
part of a certain environment,
you're gonna find where
those people are, you know.
If you wanna get high,
you're gonna look so long,
that you're gonna eventually see someone
that's doing the movement or something
of someone who's high.
So many places I've been,
when I got to Arizona,
the first dude I asked,
hell yeah, he knew
where to get everything.
You know what I mean?
And you know, I've had that
happen to me a lot here in LA.
You know, big truck drivers
and shit would pull over
and come and hit at me
and be like, hey man, can you hook me up?
I'm all the way from Kentucky.
I'm just comin' through.
This is a stop, you know.
And I'm thinkin', man, I
don't wanna hook this fool up.
But damn, once he says, hey man,
I'll give you $200 for yourself.
Now, what the fuck?
Just for pickin' up for him,
you're gonna give me 200 bucks?
And that's not just what he's giving.
He's only giving me
that from the beginning.
This is not when I bring him back the shit
and he sees it's a lot.
He's happy now.
So, he breaks me off another 40, you know.
And then before I leave, another 40.
So, you know, the fool breaks
me off three, 400, $500.
And it's happened like
maybe seven, eight times
right here in Los Angeles.
And I'm just walkin' down the street.
Been approached by women,
a man, a man and women,
and they're all truck drivers, you know.
And I'm wondering, why would they ask me?
You know, what aura or what do I give off
saying that I would know
where to find drugs?
You know, even if I'm just
walkin' down the street,
I know they can't see that
I'm high and I'm on drugs.
They can't.
But I mean, it's just
so bad that, you know,
people from another
state, cruisin' through,
stop me to buy them drugs, you know.
And I'm like, okay,
what do I gotta change?
Do I gotta change my attire?
Do I gotta change my appearance more?
You know, I'm almost 50 years old
and I'm tired of
youngsters mad doggin' me,
askin' me where I'm from.
You know what I mean?
And it's like 22 year old, 21 year old kid
askin' me where I'm from.
I'm almost 50 years old.
So, a lot of times,
I just wanna bend 'em over and spank 'em.
But then again, I knew I was
like that before, you know.
I was at that age, you know.
But I wanna share that with
you this time, you know,
about,
it don't matter where you go, man.
It's not just here in
Los Angeles and Skid Row.
It's everywhere, you know.
I've been from one tip of California
all the way to the other side
and every fuckin' city has
a ghetto, a slum, the hood.
You know, I've been places where they got,
actually got rows and rows of
what they call, slam shacks.
They're abandoned houses up on stilts
and all the people go in
there and slam in there,
live in there.
You know, there's no landlord.
There's no nothin'.
It's just rows and rows of empty houses.
And it's a trip
because I remember when
I first went in there.
It's a regular house
but it's called a slam shack.
And they got like 15 on this side,
10 on that side,
five on that side.
I've never ever seen it there.
The only place I've ever seen
it was Madera, California.
In Madera, California they have
what they call slam shacks.
And they're crazy
because everything in there.
There's a range of all kinds
of shit everywhere, you know.
The cops never go in there.
You know what I mean?
And I was like, whoa, you know.
So, every place has a place
where you can find trouble.
That's what I'm sayin', you know.
And if you don't go to find trouble,
trouble'll find you.
Trouble always finds me wherever I go.
I ended up leavin' Arizona
'cause I had to leave.
Cops were already on our tail and shit.
They were already booking all these fools.
So, I up and at 'ems got on,
came back here to LA.
But I just wanna share that
with you, Mark, you know.
I'll have some good stuff
next time, you know,
some better shit.